Speaker 1: Investigative journalist Bob Woodward
has announced he will be releasing, I believe it's
close to 20 audio recordings of his conversations
with the failed former president Donald Trump.
Some of these have started to trickle out
and they are disturbing. Now, at this point,
our threshold for saying something Trump said or
did is disturbing has gotten quite high. I mean,
looking at all of the lists of things that he did,
it really has to be something extreme to get us to
say, wow, that's crazy. And that is indeed what
we have here. Let's start with the first clip
in which Donald Trump tells Bob Woodward, I have a
plan for dealing with the pandemic. This was from,
I believe, July of 2020, but I need to deploy
it at a time that it will help my reelection,
not at the time where it would save the most
lives, not at the time that it would keep the
most people healthy at the time that it would be
best for Trump's reelection. Listen to this, Matt.
Speaker 5: More than 70,000 Americans had already
died from the virus. Now, two months after that,
in July, Trump gave Woodward a rant and he said
he finally had a plan to deal with the pandemic.
But Trump wanted.
Speaker 3: To wait
to release it until the time when.
Speaker 2: It would better help him
win reelection. Columbia, S.C., the plan.
Speaker 4: Over the next four weeks.
Speaker 3: This is.
Speaker 4: A plan.
I've got 106 days. That's a long time.
Speaker 3: You know, got to put out a. Now,
people. I remember it and
I remember that election.
Speaker 5: Oh, no. But it's not just put out the
plan, it's executed. I actually hear your story
overtly.
Speaker 1: Overtly saying,
if I do it now, people will have forgotten about
it when it's time to vote. Not if I do it now,
I might save more people. Now, that's not a
concern. Disgusting guy, completely amoral in
every way. Immoral, in fact, I would argue. Trump
compares his meeting with Kim Jong un, the North
Korean dictator, in another clip to the sort of
instant feeling of chemistry. When Trump meets
a woman and just knows whether it's all going to
happen, if you know what I mean. Listen to this.
Speaker 6: You meet somebody and you have a good
chemistry and there is a lot of trust. All right.
You meet a woman in 1/2, you know,
whether or not it's all going to happen.
Okay. We had a very good chemistry together.
Speaker 1: You mean just strange? I mean,
it's it's not about. Oh, it has romantic overtones
necessarily, although there is some. Enamored,
feeling that we get from Trump about these
dictator types. He seems enamored with the
way that President Xi of China deals with
drug dealers. He thinks it's great. He seems
enamored in a way with Putin's attitude, and he
certainly seemed enamored with Kim Jong un. Now,
interestingly, another incredible moment from
these recordings is when Trump reveals classified
information to Bob Woodward about weapons systems
and the number of weapons Russia has. And he he
is just diarrhea of the mouth. Classified
information. Now, I know. Oh, the president
can declassify whatever he wants. Sure. Do you
think Trump is carefully considering the impact
and prudence see of revealing this information
to what Bob Woodward, now he's trying to brag.
Speaker 6: I have a weapon system that
nobody's ever had in this country before.
We have stuff that you haven't even seen or heard
about. We have stuff that Putin and she had never
heard about before. Getting along with Russia is a
good thing. Not a bad thing. All right. Especially
because they have 1332 nuclear.
Speaker 3: Warheads.
Speaker 1: Trump just bragging to Bob
Woodward about all of the things that
he knows. And then maybe incredibly, Trump
gives Bob Woodward letters from Kim Jong un.
Speaker 6: Nobody else has them.
But I want you to treat them with
respect. I have an understanding. And don't say
I gave them to. Okay. I would. I think it's okay.
Normally, I witnessed I wasn't going to give them
to you. Now, will you make a protest out of it?
Speaker 5: No, I dictated.
Speaker 3: Them into a tape recorder. Really?
Speaker 1: Isn't that the best? What? You
make a photo stat of the letters or something?
Interestingly, Woodward is sort of handling
the documents with more care than Trump. And
what I mean by that is Woodward isn't creating
physical copies that could then be lost. Bob
Woodward It seems to have more consideration for
the sensitive nature of these documents than even
Trump himself. These are just for little clips,
for little previews of what may be to come from
these audiotapes. I told you folks years ago it
will take years to learn the full insanity of
what took place during that four year period.
And indeed, that is that is the case. It is
taking years for all of this stuff to come out.
And it is disturbing as it is extraordinary.